what up guys dagger recipes of blank
Square Productions I'm a director
Venezuelan American I was an immigrant
27 years undocumented but we still here
standing and we're here with blue like
Kev let's see ya
bootleg hit podcast we got a special
guest in here the homie Edgar is here
from blank Square Productions this guy
is uh I'm gonna let you kind of
introduce yourself and just tell
everybody what you do man
oh man Venezuelan American director
um just having fun and [ __ ] [ __ ] up
right now yeah you're like uh one of the
I mean I would say the top two or three
video directors in the game right now I
appreciate that you've done I mean you
did the Box video
uh I mean you've done so many videos so
like what are like the bigger like just
kind of run down some of your obviously
you got started with Russ we'll get into
that but like give me some of your like
highlights of the last like couple of
years uh honestly
um so that's a confusion I'm a
production company and I'm also a
director so so your your company is
blank Square yeah so blank square and so
basically uh I have 12 directors on my
company and then I'll including myself
so then I direct projects and they also
do projects
um I like to be involved in a little bit
everything just kind of like just about
the culture and just showing people how
to get things and how to treat artists
um but yeah it comes into a situation
where I think a lot of the people always
like damn your videos are everywhere
it's like no my company is everywhere so
what about your company what what are
the bigger videos of the last few years
that blank Square's handled oh man you
know we just did the handsomer remix
video with Tiffany haddish that was cool
that one was dope it was like a little
mini movie yeah 100 I was just trying to
bring back that like that old Chris
Robinson old you know like Jesse Torero
skits type of videos but um on other
videos though uh what else yeah they're
just so many
um the videos that were about to come up
is like you know we're shooting Nikki
next week so that's gonna be cool
um can't see the record yet but well I
think it's the one she's probably been
teasing right the freaky girl record no
just you know surprise for everybody you
know what I'm saying but um but yeah I'm
excited about that and yeah man just
there's so many videos at this point
like I was just in Mexico shooting a big
artist out with their name Diana Paola
so and she has a huge following I was
out compared to kind of like you know
she's like that new girl in Mexico on
the rise and yeah it's pretty cool man
just to try to like just work with
different artists and different levels
of their career right uh there was a
video which video did you do that Tiana
Trump was in
oh the throat Baby remix yeah throat
baby yeah I'd be forgetting all the
videos we'll be doing honestly but that
was a crazy ass video yeah a lot of
people were talking about it especially
at the baby scene where yeah
yeah you know it's funny because uh me
and my friends were honestly we're just
like smoking weed and we're just like in
my living room and we're just talking
about it I play the record and we all
honestly just came up with a scene and
we were just like having fun with it and
we're like yo how nasty can you get with
it and but still like making it in a
cool way and yeah one of my friends was
like yo what if uh the baby was uh you
know surfing down a tongue and then
someone else said like yeah like this
and then I was like yeah we'll put the
goggles on them and then like we just
started like collaborating on the idea
and then we're like you know what we
wrote Into the treatment and uh lvrn who
manages BRS cash was like we love the
idea we want to be provocative and and
it worked it worked yeah what is like uh
for you been the most creatively
challenging video to pull off
oh man definitely uh I shot this video
for Russ they misunderstood it was shot
on motion control so basically that that
camera moves like this like a robot and
yeah that was that was kind of a that
was kind of a challenge I had one day to
do it
um the budget wasn't like where it had
to be for that type of video but I
really pushed it uh gave up my rate and
I was like yo I really want to make
something different and at the time you
know a lot of like the the media was
talking about him and xxyz and I was
like I really want to highlight
everything in a video you know and just
do it in one take and seamlessly and I
think I did a great job of it yeah uh
for people who don't know uh give me
because you came to America as an
immigrant right yeah I came here when I
was 11 months old I was born in Valencia
Venezuela and uh would you end up coming
to Florida
no actually I moved to Houston okay for
a year so me and my family just
immigrant story you know uh we were in a
garage and about like uh 10 months after
we moved to Houston we uh you know we
dipped out to Florida
but what people don't know and like this
is probably the first time I'll see it
on camera is like I actually came to
America because I had like a you know
like a life-threatening surgery in my
brain because when I was a kid I hit my
head on a metal bed so when I hit my
middle when I got hit in the head I
basically uh like no one knew because it
was an internal wound [ __ ] so I had I
started having internal bleeding in my
brain so then my aunt comes home drunk
at three in the morning um from a
nightclub basically hears me crying in
the middle of night picks me up and I'm
purple
I go to the hospital and at the time you
know Venezuela the health care is not
the greatest over there so they're like
oh he's having an allergic reaction just
give them some antibiotics and he'll be
fine but then my mom's like no
something's wrong so it took me to a
private Clinic my dad before was going
back and forth between the U.S and
America so he had an American Express
credit card so he put the whole
operation on American Express and that
was making it made him go bankrupt
that's the reason why we came to this
country [ __ ] yeah so then we moved to
Houston because my dad had a friend over
there we stayed in his garage for like a
10 months 11 months and then my dad was
like damn this is
this is us it's not our Vibes I'm gonna
try to go to Florida um there's more
Spanish people there so that's why we
went to Florida and I moved to Fort
Lauderdale and then like in my later
years in high school I kind of like
started making my shift to Miami damn
yeah so it's almost like
I was definitely amazing the biggest
gift and curse situation yeah yeah had a
crazy traumatic surgery but if it wasn't
for that you probably wouldn't be here
right oh yeah and then it's nice because
it's like it always gives me perspective
of like damn they try to take me out
early you know and I'm still here so no
that's crazy so like uh you end up kind
of getting to Miami
um I saw I didn't know that you were uh
interning for Lex shout out to my guy
Lexi I was just with him last week uh in
Miami yeah he's a legend no he's the guy
uh so yeah with Lex you can still look
up my tweets back from like 2010
um yeah I graduated high school and if
people don't know like I I came to the
country and overstayed my uh my tourist
visa so I was undocumented for 27 years
right and so that means when you're
undocumented you can't work you can't
drive you can't you know you can't do
anything mostly like that Americans
could
um so yeah Lex uh I I tweeted him after
high school because I want to go to
college I had some scholarships but I
was going to go to Virginia Tech for
architecture and I couldn't go because I
wasn't a citizen so then I was like all
right cool what up what else can I do I
used to walk around school with a little
camera just filming people like little
Vlog stuff right and I knew how to edit
so I'm like oh maybe I can get into like
content or something like that and I met
Lex uh because I tweeted uh I was just
tweeting a bunch of places I was like yo
like I didn't even know like how to
submit my reps but I was just like Lex
promotions um I would love to enter for
you like the tweet's still up and um
yeah he hit me back he's like all right
cool come to our office I came to his
office the next day and then he was like
all right cool what do you what do you
want to do and I was like honestly
anything and I entered at five companies
I interned at Hit Factory
um mix Studios uh Lex promotion mix
Studios with uh uh Jason Jason does the
Imaging from the radio station yeah the
uh yeah the mix show that's what it was
called yeah no and then um and then uh I
interned at uh twinnight.com and also uh
for poetboy music group um under freezy
for and uh you know as a graphic
designer because I learned Photoshop in
high school so so I took like the traits
that I knew about editing in Photoshop
and like you know Lex makes Flyers so I
started making flies for them and then I
just started just you know how old were
you at this point I was like fresh out
of high school yeah 17. that's when I
graduated so you were 17 like helping
out with flyers and yeah doing nightclub
flyers for like Club dream and all those
that Miami scene at the time you know
damn were you at the I know the dude
from the mix groups got these yeah from
take one down to he's got these he's got
these Iron Man [ __ ] statues did were
you there when he had those Jason maybe
maybe I don't know yeah yeah so how did
obviously you go from that
um I know that like uh
will really kind of help pop off you as
a director was working with Russ right
yeah so Russ was based in Atlanta yeah
he was based in Atlanta and the funny
story about it still is based in Atlanta
yeah he's still based um but yeah funny
thing about Russ is like uh prior to
Russ I was working with this kid named
Jake Miller he was a popular shout out
to Jake Miller I know Jake Miller yeah
yeah he's uh well my roommates and one
of my really good friends and I really
he's at Empire now I think yeah he's an
Empire yeah and um yeah so then um as
Russ uh as I found Russ I actually found
him and Alicia Cara at the same time wow
and I was like I was on a rapport.com
and I saw both of those artists and I
was like I don't know if that site still
exists but I was like like trying to
find a new artist to work with
um and yeah Alicia Carr lived in Toronto
so I was like oh I couldn't travel so
then I was like all right cool let me
let me um focus on Rust so I dm'd them
and I said let's shoot everything and he
hit me back and he's like bro of course
and at that time I was already doing
videos because you know I came you know
under kind of Khalid earlier before that
so what were some of like your earlier
videos before Russ oh man
um you know I really started I really
want to give a shout out to Kika we the
best because um he connected me with Ace
Hood and the Ace Hood connected me with
Khalid Cali connected me with like the
golden Miami hip-hop scene which was
like Lil Wayne you know Drake Ricky Ross
right I was around all those guys
because of uh DJ Khaled and before that
like you know I was dping a lot for like
you know directors like Dre films and
John Jay in Miami so like I was doing
like you know tat on my arms and you got
me um Don't Panic with Rick Ross and uh
Meek Mill and Yo Gotti and I was just
kind of like there's a I remember the
spiff TV and the Dre films era videos
yeah I was looking up to guys like that
coming up in Miami just like yo these
guys I remember there's an artist named
Murph music down there and I was just
like yo like I remember one time I was
watching this video I was like yo shoot
Dre's like crazy out here he's killing
it and I was like this is what I kind of
want to do and he took me under his wing
and just kind of like let me um you know
because I knew a little bit more about
the cinematography side right so he
would direct and I would DP which is
like the Director of Photography yeah
what is so for people who don't know
because uh obviously directing shooting
running the camera DP what is it what is
the DP in the grand scheme of like the
process of a video getting done uh I
would explain it the best as a
cinematographer so the guy who you know
does the lighting and you know talks to
the g e crew which is the grip in
electric to make sure you know
everything's kind of so set in tone you
got me and you're really um you're
really in charge of the look of the film
or the video so
back back in the day difference yeah
different time there's before you were
using like DPS and grips and all that
I'm assuming all the early rust stuff
was just done with just your camera I
think I heard you tell a story about the
uh the one in the forest what's that
video oh what they want what they want
and just like how you guys just kind of
like winged that video a bit yeah
um
do you feel like
because because they're still obviously
listen
they're still great videos that are
being done for like [ __ ] twelve
hundred dollars fifteen hundred dollars
people who have a you know a Sony A7 II
with the right lens that could pull off
a good enough video right that would
make sense that was a setup right there
oh yeah the A7 II Oh I had the A7 one
and then the Ronin and yeah just just
pull up yeah yeah
um at what point in time
did things start to change for you where
you were able to kind of because like
obviously things really start to change
when you don't have to handle every
aspect of a video yeah you know because
I'm you've been in that position where
you gotta shoot it you gotta edit it and
you're like it's like damn and and now
you not once budgets start opening up
you could probably have a lot more
you know because I know what it's like I
have artists that's like Dude we've got
to keep this [ __ ] under this amount of
money yeah so the idea has got to be not
as Grandy or well that's what like um
you know when I was working for Ace Hood
and Khaled like
um I was shooting videos for them but
they're paying me like fifteen hundred
two thousand and I was like all right
let's just get a little video but what I
was doing I was shooting videos for
other artists locally and then I would
charge them like twenty five hundred
three thousand so I'll take like half of
my rate and then put it into college
video or Aces video because I knew they
had the eyes you got me at the time
Worldstar was out um you know I did a
lot of videos on Worldstar so you were
kind of like reinvest in your your money
into the [ __ ] that you know people would
see yeah because I I like I believe in
like people not the idea so I was just
like I knew Ace Hood at the time he had
hustle out and he was like big in my
city so I was a great guy too yeah and
um yeah and he just like gave me a
chance he's like yo let's go rock let's
go shoot videos every week and then Cal
would give him you know a few grand or
he would pay for himself I'm not sure
who had the money but and then we would
take care of that and it ended up
leading me to a lot of features and you
know working with like guys like Evan
costume who's a songwriter yeah yeah who
introduced me to other people and this
and that and I was around the studio the
whole time so I met Like Fat Joe Buster
Rhymes J Cole all these people early
early days
um at the we the best studio so shout
out to them would you say um
Lincoln with a single specific artist
like Russ because I do feel like uh on
the music side yeah that helps producers
right if you're a producer I always tell
producers like yo if you're a producer
find it an artist that you can come up
with yeah craft a sound with yeah and
then build with that person and would
you say you kind of did something
similar on the video side with Russ oh
100
um yeah I said one time like you know
instead of trying to build with like
Jay-Z and Kanye and you know the little
Wayne's of the world I was like let me
build with like you know the Russ's the
little babies you know the Roddy Riches
of the world so we can you know grow
together and take it to the next level
because I at one point you know everyone
saw me as the cameraman and they were
like yo you're just a behind the scene
guy and you're really good at that and
we're gonna keep you here so like a lot
of people were just like they never saw
me in the light and they didn't know
that I could do that that's why I
decided uh um when I left Khalid I was
like I'm gonna go find another artist
and it was Jake Miller she was a kid who
lived like 15 minutes away and Jake
Miller had a wave yeah he was like it
was like Justin Bieber Austin Mahone
Jake Miller Shawn Mendes and um yeah we
were we started working with him and uh
yeah things just started slowly you know
growing and then I started realizing
that the the music was you know slowly
connecting but it was really the YouTube
videos that really started blowing them
up and and then I was like and I was you
know thank for my work ethic and his um
and his vision as a Entertainer and then
we just kind of started working that way
we started dropping Vlogs almost every
day and it were about 10 minutes so I
was just cranking them out and he
started blowing up he went on tour I was
like yo me and my friend um John he
started the tour because I couldn't
travel at the time right but then like I
think like three weeks later I got my my
first license at 24 and then I was able
to travel and
um yeah I ended up chilling with Jake
and for about two three years just
building up with him until he got signed
a Warner Brothers and they gave me my
first chance to direct the ten thousand
dollar music video so that was the first
time I ever got a DP a producer and was
able to do something finally you know
that's fire
uh what's your turnaround time on a 10
minute vlog
for video editors that are watching this
honest honestly because that's the
biggest gripe if you hire someone to
edit video it's the turnaround time well
for me um you know like like I couldn't
work legally right so like you gotta
understand that like I was just like I
want to make a good impression on
everybody and I didn't want to lose the
job because they were paying me under
the table right so it was just like and
this is because of your immigration
status yeah I would do a 10 minute video
Lily every day like how long would that
take you I'd probably probably take me a
lot at the time maybe like five six
hours to edit it you got me so I'll
shoot all day and then at night I would
edit it and then we didn't do that on
tour and then that's funny because the
the stuff that I did with Jake Miller
actually started spilling off into Russ
because I had that work ethic that I was
basically when I when I came to Russ and
I started doing his music videos for
free then I was like yo
um I want to go on tour with you and
he's like bro you want to come on tour
with me I'm like for sure bro like I'm
here to help you I want to see you blow
because I think you're going to be a big
artist right and he's like all right
cool so we went to the Did It My Way
tour and you know he started I think
Chicago was like 75 people it was like
very small shows right and I knew from
the Jake experience that I was like I
could shoot these videos and make 75
people look like 200 in the video and
make it look more amp through the
editing you got me and then that's what
happened and the next you know shows
started getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and now he's you know
17 000 at the Hollywood Bowl so it's
crazy yeah start a stable Center yeah
yeah and then I came out on stage on
both of them and he's like and he's so
dope that he lets you do that and lets
you be a part of that moment and that's
why I was big up Russ and you know he
taught me a lot about just you know I
knew I was manifesting but I never knew
what that word meant and like he kind of
gave it a definition for me so like it
really inspired me to like you know do
the stuff that I do now and I always
give my hats off to Russ because a loyal
guy uh trustworthy gives it is all
um and you know very inspiring I think
uh Russ is like one of the more
inspiring people for me personally uh
like the last I don't know dude because
I'm just like there's this dude makes no
excuses and I appreciate the fact that
like
he's so like most people try to hold on
to the game yeah this guy just openly
shares it with everybody and inspired me
to do the same thing with videos yeah
it's like dude like if you're not
listening to this guy as an artist and
like applying what he's saying to like
your own personal [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
crazy yeah it's like either you're a
hater or you just like I don't
understand because I'm like yo he's
giving away all the game the most labels
managers they don't want you to have any
of this [ __ ] like it's it's crazy but
you know I think when you know when and
I have a very like we have a very we
always talk about this how we have very
similar trajectories just in different
paths for sure and it's just like you
know you get rejected so much and you're
just like you have this chip on your
shoulder you know people telling you oh
you're just the cameraman so many times
or I'm telling him yo you're just a
producer you're not really a rapper or
you're not good enough or all those
things and all those like you know uh I
guess attacks they have on you like they
they build up and then it's like you
start realizing once you get it you're
like you know what um we don't need to
you know depend on anyone else yeah
depend on anyone else and also when you
find happiness helping others find their
happiness yeah I mean and that's I think
more of our agenda now and um I can't
speak for him but I know that's kind of
like his wa his Vibe you know he just
wants to help and he wants that kid who
reminds himself of Russ when he was 20
years old like to be like yo you can
still do this and that's why I post
things like that too oh yeah for sure
you post a lot of motivational [ __ ] 100
man and you have like a lot of old
footage like you got a ton of that's the
thing is like I knew like I knew I knew
I was going to be something one day I
just like I didn't know how I was going
to get there but I'm like let me
document everything because that's
honestly what I do so I was like let me
document everything and have this very
like like I guess I would compare to the
Kanye West genius and I'm like yeah yeah
yeah for sure and you got to document
stuff like that just so you can look
back on and be like look I was talking
that [ __ ] in 2012 I was talking that
[ __ ] in 2010 and 2022 like
you go back and check the receipt you
know if you want to do the homework
you'll see that like I've always had
this confidence and I've always been
this type of person right so it's like
don't tell me who I am because I know
who I was you get I mean I was just
ahead of where I was at the time we got
to stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our folks at my bookie ladies
and gentlemen [ __ ] NFL season
is approaching my favorite time of the
year God damn it it's good times and the
Rams versus the bills is happening
kicking off the whole regular season and
there's no way to get ready for that
regular season like getting ready for
that winning season all right I'm
talking about putting some [ __ ]
money in your pocket you could be a
veteran better like me or you could be a
first time better and you just want to
get a little taste of the action my
bookie has got you because right now
they got that double deposit bonus if
you sign up at mybookie.ag right now go
to my bookie it's quick and easy let's
say you put 250 bucks in you get 500 to
gamble with that's right it's a double
deposit bonus but you have to use the
promo code
root leg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g it's also in the
description of this video you can just
click the link and you're in there so go
to mybookie.com use that double deposit
bonus by using the promo code bootleg
you gotta register today use it and
let's get this NFL season [ __ ]
cracking I'm talking listen I don't even
know the line of the Rams Bills game
it's about a week out only some change
away depending on what the [ __ ] you're
watching this but
Bill's money line what are we doing all
right my bookie sign up use that promo
code bootleg right now and get that
double deposit bonus if you put in a
thousand dollars you get two thousand
dollars to gamble with you put a hundred
you get 200. it's that [ __ ] easy my
bookie go run it up let's get back to
the interview okay hypothetically
speaking there's uh somebody who wants
to
shoot music videos yeah kind of follow
your path
they got five grand in the bank what
camera what lens what are they getting
to get the most bang for their Buck to
try to you know maybe they're in
Missoula Montana and they want to start
shooting music videos for their homie
what do they what are they getting give
me the breakdown of like the gear that
you could get for about five grand
honestly if you're trying to get to
music videos I always tell people like
you got to believe in the artist you got
me like you got to listen to the music
and like I think equipment is definitely
you know helpful and I would definitely
rock with that Ronin and that Sony a7s
and you know just put pop-up memory card
in there and just have fun any sort of
lens they're broken on you know lens set
you know okay yeah low light you can
shoot at night time you can shoot at day
um really really clean glass but um and
you probably get that all under like
probably four grand but I always say
like it doesn't matter who you shoot
videos for if like the song is not good
if the artist doesn't have that
confidence that he's going to be the
biggest artist and I saw that a lot in
myself so then I started trying to find
artists with that same energy you got me
so when I saw rest I was like yo I was
listening to the music and he's he's
talking that [ __ ] if you listen you got
me sure and even back in the day like I
was like 2014 2015 he was you know he
was rapping about like how he's going to
be the biggest one day and like that's
the type of confidence you want an
artist and that's that's kind of what I
bet on you got me and I was like and
same thing with Jake Miller like you
know he had a really beautiful family
and they were also working he had a
manager that managed Jason Derulo and he
had a good team set up and I'm like oh
this guy's gonna win yeah I mean it's
not just like the music it's also like
the structure and you know their
surroundings and they had that so so you
said the Sony a7s yeah the Sony a7s the
Ronin um the Rokinon lens set and you
know um get some ND filters you know and
some circular polarizers you know if
you're shooting outside and um honestly
a lot of YouTube tutorials because
that's how I learned you know would you
say Final Cut or Premiere
um I'm gonna go Premiere but I started
off Final Cut
um nowadays Final Cut has its perks so
does Premiere so it's just about you
know yeah I know people some people use
both and then there are people who are
just so married to like one or the other
like I I know Final Cut guys like him
and with the man Bun over there just
won't let go Final Cut
well you know it's honestly really just
depends on who you are and what you're
trying to do but I also like I think
there's a there's a there's a big thing
and also like when I started learning
because I didn't learn this early is um
you know a story you know what are you
trying to say what's a theme you know
what's the universal theme that
everyone's going to connect to you got
me like when we shoot rust is exposed
and we basically pull up a bunch of
archival concert footage we shot that
video Lily in two minutes it was snowing
in Spokane Washington and I literally
said yo stand right there we're gonna
shoot one performance I took that
performance I mixed it up archive
archival footage of the tour and then I
just basically put up text you got me um
same thing with what they want you know
it was a 40 minute video shot that's
crazy you know I just went there and I
was like damn and we're the first video
that coloring on that [ __ ] was so fire
yeah and I learned it through a YouTube
tutorial you got me and um I was there
on YouTube like looking at how to do
infrared and then going back to Da Vinci
um that's a coloring program and then I
was like boom and I was just doing that
back and forth and that video was funny
because uh we were shooting this video
and he was dressing all white he had a
glass of wine and we're like like this
is kind of whack and we're like shooting
this for 30 minutes and we're like this
ain't it so as we're driving back um
through a Botanical Garden in Atlanta
um I see this shed and I'm like yo let's
stop there and I remember I think um I
think Travis Scott and um T.I had a
video called upper echelon that was shot
in like a cabin and I was like maybe I
could do something here and then I
walked to the cab and I was like yeah I
could shoot this how about this Russ
let's do like a few takes and let's see
what we get and we did that um he was
performing he was having fun and then I
took it home and then I'm like damn this
video kind of sucks and then I was like
how can I make it different and then in
the editing process that's when I made
the leaves infrared and then next you
know that's kind of like what set this
video off yeah no for sure the coloring
was crazy I feel like was that like uh
that was that was before that record was
technically that was before he had his
his deal right yeah we shot um the first
video we ever shot was losing control
then it was what they want then it was
do it myself then it was pull the
trigger and I showed the first three
videos for free and then the fourth
video was um uh pull the trigger which
Russ was you know at that point had
enough money to you know pay me like
seven thousand dollars for the video
[ __ ] yeah that's great yeah that's
[ __ ] dope man 100
um now that you're kind of like in the
position that you're in right do you
because I don't know how the video game
works like obviously there's a lot of
people who are doing what you're doing
but like are you do you like pitch for
videos yeah sometimes or are you just
people coming to you like for example
you said that you manifested the Nicki
Minaj video coming up right
which is a big deal
um how did that one come up like is that
something where the label reaches out to
you yeah so it's also it's featuring
someone else as well that's why I didn't
want to mention the name right and then
um so yeah that person put me in contact
and then next you know we connected and
nowadays it's more relationships and um
I barely pitch only if it's like a
really crazy opportunity like someone
that I got really was like damn like I
can't I don't have a relationship with
that person right but for the newer
generation of artists like you know most
of them know me as in my videos so same
thing like with whiz when I was shooting
whiz he just you know I reached out to
him on a DM and he hit me back and we
started you know chopping up as homies
first you did the Ice style necklace and
the badass [ __ ] right no I didn't
think I style necklace I just did a
badass okay the baddest [ __ ] video is
crazy yeah thank you yeah and um and
yeah so it's just like building
relationships with people you got me in
really taking your time to really
understand them pull up to the studio
listen to the music right you know try
to just connect with them first as
people and then from there like be like
all right cool when the right time and
it's organic let's make it happen and
that's what happened with whiz you know
I think we kind of skipped over some of
the accolades you have though can we
kind of just do you know off the top of
your head
and give people full context you go from
being uh immigrant who lives in a garage
with his parents in Houston for 11
months
to have you know give me if you had to
give me the top five off the top of your
head probably just like you're saying
views on YouTube videos that you have
just so we can kind of set the table
your company yeah oh [ __ ] well you know
Russ videos you know went crazy losing
control I think is that like I don't
know 300 400 million views [ __ ] crazy
shots um that was the first video shot
so it's very important you know for me
to say that
um yeah there's so many videos honestly
like there's just so many did you do the
late at night video late at night no I
didn't do that without Director X yeah
okay yeah that was Ronnie rich now we
didn't do that one you did the box which
is the yeah yeah we produced The Bronx
it was directed by a kid named Christian
who was uh director at our company yeah
so when you like when you are in in the
producer role when it's like you're and
you have 12 directors so you said that
work for you yeah
um as a producer like how much input do
you have on everything well I think what
I do is like I just try to lead by
experience right yeah I mean because a
lot of directors have the talent but
sometimes you know I think you know
filmmakers can get a little weird you
got me and they're like they're not
they're more worried about the real than
the artist's career and I try to worry
about both and I think that's what makes
my video so special and because you know
before I was even like doing any video
stuff like I actually like I used to in
high school I used to like uh freestyle
battle rap people like and I was going
to school to school rapping and stuff
and I wanted to be a rapper right and
then I was like and then I started like
you kind of you know you're growing up
you're a Spanish kid um you know like
you know you're like in a predominantly
black neighborhood and you're like damn
I can't really rap you know like I don't
have that confidence as a 17 year old so
I was like you know what let me pick up
a camera maybe I could just shoot you
got me and then that's kind of what
happened and um yeah so like I think
like I also am kind of in a way like
some like some deep down part inside me
I have this music artist ability in me
that just wants to like understand who
artists are and what they're trying to
accomplish you know you also have a
record label yes do everything records
yeah with the homie Jordan from QC right
yes 100 so yeah um talk about the artist
y'all got the I forget the young ladies
yeah I have my record label do
everything records and he has the wasted
Youth and we merged and we did a
partnership with Warner to sign a girl
named iv4 that's right yeah yeah so
what's that I mean obviously that's
that's a whole nother bag of that was
something to prove to myself just
because like you know I was working with
so many artists and um helping them
develop and I was like you know what I
want something that I can like you know
stamp my name on and be like yo you know
I really started from the ground up and
and like you know without any confusion
and just being like you know sometimes
you're like oh is it me or was it them
or was it us and I think it's a us thing
but of course it should be enough yeah
and then unless you're Russ then it's
like really just you and him because yes
was like managing himself yeah but um it
was cool because with Ivy um yeah she
liked my photo and you know she saw Russ
and then she saw who shot his videos and
it's so funny how like one thing
connects to the other right and then I
was looking for a girl with box sprays
for a music video for Atlantic Records
and I saw her uh I saw her face and I
was like oh she would be a perfect model
I reached out to her and then I was like
yo do you want to be in this video and
she's like well I live in New York but
yeah I'm down I was like yeah the
video's tomorrow so how soon can you get
here and she's like oh well the flight's
like 800 and I was like music video
budget at the time I'm like yeah I don't
got the money so she flew herself in
still met with me and then um yeah
pulled up at me like at two in the
morning and like sang for me and I was
just like yo you know what give me 90
days give me three months and I'll come
back for you and I just said that
because I was busy doing some other
videos at the time and Lily on the 90th
day I called her back and I said yo I
partnered with Jordan I'm like yo let's
do this together we all hopped on the
phone and we did that within a week we
had a million dollar offer from Sylvia
Rona epic [ __ ] yeah because in that week
we made five songs and we shot five
videos all in that same week
um a guy named Christopher and acunte
saw
um Ivy and walked us into epic and he
was about to leave there because he was
like the senior or whatever a r and I
decided uh you know what I'm gonna turn
it down and I'm gonna develop this girl
so we took two and a half years we also
got a deal from QC at the time
Interscope and a few other places and we
turned out all the deals because I knew
she wasn't ready also like I'm sure the
leverage wasn't great like you had a
million dollar advance yeah but you know
the terms probably weren't the greatest
no 100 for new artists like that yeah so
what we did was we waited two years uh
two three years and she was living in my
house honestly I had this really big
closet and she slept in there and made
it a bedroom
um I had roommates at the time I was
roommates with Jake uh and in this house
in Sherman Oaks and yeah so she just you
know she dug it out and I said look if
you listen to me you know you'll be in a
much better position in the next few
years and that's what happened and then
we ended up doing a JV partnership with
our label in uh Warner and you know
Benning for her which she keeps you know
keeps her tour rights and things like
that and it was very it was very
important for us to do that especially
you know you know seeing Russ and his
deals yeah like I saw him sign his first
deal with Columbia I was there and I
filmed it so it's like I saw the
contract and I knew that I'm like yo
this guy won he beat the system and I
was like this is I could do this too and
I think that's what Russ is so inspiring
because it's like he's really showing
you guys how to get it yeah I mean but
yeah most artists will go for that that
million dollars and then be stuck in a
deal and then once they blow through it
they'll be on Instagram complaining yeah
it's sad because you know once after
taxes and after you pay your lawyers and
after you pay you know your manager if
you have one at the time and like which
you probably will do you have a manager
yeah I have a management okay yeah so I
managed to buy a company called
uncomment which is a division of macro
and they do movies like Judas and black
Messiah and like fences and cool stuff
too or you can just try to get into
producing movies oh that's already
happening so yeah we got four projects
in development right now including a TV
series about my life so I'm excited
about that yeah so you're doing like the
TV thing all that yeah that'll be big
man yeah I'm just trying to bring that
same energy I bring the music videos
into the film world but it's also like
you know I was like I want people to
know that I was a hood director right
like I was a guy who just pulled up to
the Hood shooting identity theft
scammers and and Miami just pulling up
drug dealers whatever are all these
videos still on YouTube 100 you know um
yeah everyone in North Miami at the time
you know from The The J bucks to the DZ
the rappers the flow kids the young fees
to the icebergs you know all the Lex
promotions gang who introduced me to so
many local artists like I started
shooting videos for all of them and I
always thank them because like those
guys literally like they didn't care if
I didn't have documentation they didn't
care nothing they paid me cash under the
table and capture and it really kept me
afloat yeah it really kept me afloat
yeah and then it was just it's kind of
crazy just to think about it honestly
appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at Bluetooth they got you
handled fellas and Etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick Bluetooth
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels I
mean like LeBron his first three seasons
with the heat type levels I mean your
wife will thank you for it everybody
will thank you for it [ __ ] even if you
just take a Bluetooth and jerk your dick
it's a it's a stronger jerk I swear to
God God stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure
you're gonna be beating your dick like a
stole something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg right now and you're gonna
get your first month free and this is
the great thing about Bluetooth the same
active ingredients as Viagra and scialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discreet
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
think me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the blue shoe he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview how different
is um
trying to get into the movie in like a
TV game oh no it's a learning curve
because you know um like I didn't grow
up having like you know like a mentor to
kind of like you know guide me in the
film World
um or even in the directing world so it
was a lot of like first times for me and
I had a lot of trial and error
um but I'm very grateful I have those
experiences because they made me who I
am today but um yeah the Hollywood
system is just a totally different game
and it's really about you know learning
it's not just about oh you can make a
visually compelling music video it's
like can you tell a story yeah yeah I
mean can you you know keep an audience
engaged and that's kind of what I'm
learning now so I've been reading a lot
of books you know like there's a really
good one called uh you know making
movies by Cindy lament that I just
finished and just trying to connect and
you know surround my circle with more
people who do movies rather than just
people who do music you know
if you after your first movie I think of
this movie up here belly Hype Williams
directed it 100 and then he stopped
directing movies we'll see but that
movie visually was so [ __ ] crazy now
the storyline was kind of [ __ ] it's to
me the best worst movie ever but I just
like wish you would have kept going yeah
but sometimes with the Hollywood system
and that's why it's like it's so it's so
important to always keep going and keep
thriving because you know the first
movie who knows you might it might not
do good it might on paper look bad but
everyone knows and especially in hip-hop
that belly is a classic it's a classic I
mean like how many times in music videos
you see the treatment reference to
walking in of DMX 100 you got me and
it's just like and I think that movie
made more impact than noise at the box
office no for sure and I think like it
was definitely a DVD win yeah but they
sold so many [ __ ] DBS my Studios
don't see that you know they're gonna be
like all right how much did you make
opening week right oh snap we spent all
this money and we didn't make that back
or we only made that back in a little
bit now this don't make no sense you
know we rather shoot uh we rather do I
don't know a b flying around the you
know I was in this area are you to the
point now that like if you're like okay
I want to do a TV show based on my life
I can just bankroll that myself and then
shop it around to a distributor yeah and
it's funny because I came in that in the
music space like being that way like oh
if I believe in Russ I'm gonna put my
own money up and shoot a video for him
or if I believe in this artist I'm gonna
put my money up or if little baby gives
me 10K I'm gonna put an extra 5K to make
it even better you got me and that's
kind of how I flipped it but in the
movie world you start realizing it's not
just about the money it's also about the
Partnerships and the distribution of the
people who you're partnering with and so
like I I had a TV series and I was going
to shoot the pilot and I was like yo I'm
gonna spend my own money but then you
know I had some you know some people
some OG's be like yo you don't got to do
that we can find money and we can find
the right Partners strategically so when
the movie comes out we all bring assets
to it and it's just not you putting it
out on Instagram and being like buy my
movie you know because it'll probably
fail you know that's what I was gonna
say because I'm not sure like I'm not
super hip to the to that side of the
entertainment business but to me it
feels a little and I'm probably wrong
but it feels like a little similar to
like if you're an independent filmmaker
I guess kind of like a record deal like
if you have a something that you believe
in and you can produce it yourself you
can't wait and that's why I decided to
um and while my company and the reason
is called Blaine squares because you
know you really start at a blank slate
and I know that you got to fill it in
yourself and that's kind of why I call
the company that and yeah so I decided
to move my best friends um to my
production company
um I decided to own my own equipment so
I bought cameras you know Lexus and
lenses and tripods and monitors I
started my own Post House you know that
does editing and color correcting and
VFX and I open up all these companies
simultaneously as my business and
production company were growing and
that's why now I'm able to be
self-sufficient so now if I want to
shoot a short film all right maybe I
just have to pay the actors and some
crew you know I don't have to pay the
camera I don't have all that in-house
and I kind of just took it off the
toilet paper model you know yeah back in
like 2015 I think I saw like an article
where he's like he's developing
something crazy extravagant and I was
like I can do that too but at a smaller
scale and I just started instead of
taking the money that I made for music
videos and put it in my pocket or spend
out at the club I was like let me buy a
camera let me buy this and now I still
rent my gear out and it's like a side
hustle you know yeah so you'll yeah not
only are you shooting the [ __ ] but if
somebody needs cameras your company will
ran out gear honestly like and it's
funny like a lot of directors
um you know in the music video world
like we edit their videos and they don't
even know it's my company you got me and
it's just like you know it's just like I
try to get a bag everywhere yeah I mean
it's all left to everybody but it's just
funny because you know I think sometimes
as music video directors you know you
feel like there's only one spot which
that's not true we can all win and it's
just like and that's kind of why like
even being on this platform I want to
say that because I think what we got to
do a better job of is you know
developing the community because you
know music video directors it's like
different than any other art form we get
billions of views but we don't get a
percentage of videos yeah I mean like we
don't get to know part of the YouTube ad
we don't get another thing like you get
a one time for a photo or like a a movie
so it's like we get a one-time fee and
yeah as much as it's nice that one time
fee especially if you're a bigger
director
um yeah that doesn't that's that's not
passive income thank God I have other
companies that do that but this like you
know and I think that's what we have to
come together and stick together to make
a change because I feel like you know um
I think over like as a director I think
I have over like 20 billion views that's
great just to think about that you know
you know who's uh cut uh shout out to
the Russell the Russell yeah with him
right now I'm gonna say I know he's been
doing a good job of when he puts music
out he puts it out the distro kid yeah
and then he'll he'll give he'll split
everybody in like if it's a video
director I want to give a shout out to
Russell because he actually texted me
and he was like you know what man I'm
gonna give you a piece of the video
that's what I'm saying and he's like and
he's like and he's like bro I want I
want to see you win and I'm like that's
selfless energy is something that like
really inspires me and like it always
reminds me same thing with our directors
at my company I made sure they see the
bid if there's a few a few thousand
dollars left over in the production I'll
be like yo we're gonna cut this evenly
you got me and showing them that but I
think a lot of production companies
don't do that because it's just like why
would they do that they could just
pocket the money and you know guys like
Russ and you know thank God to my dad
who's a good guy just like taught me
that character of being like very
selfless and being very open when it
comes to business so nothing has to be
weird later you know because I really
really really like depend on my
relationships you got me hey what year
did you actually become a citizen
um 2022 2020. so like did that make just
life much easier for you in terms of
just like being able to move around yeah
well think about it like you know when
Russ went to Europe I couldn't go
um when Jake went to Europe I couldn't
go when he went to Dubai I couldn't go
when he went to Saudi Arabia I couldn't
go like a lot of life experiences that
could have maybe shaped me or molded me
to see different types of cultures I
missed out on um yeah same thing with um
you know Ace Hood when he was going to
Europe I remember like my best friend a
kid I grew up with his name's Ivan
Barrios so you might know him as a
photographer
and you know Ivan let me borrow his
first camera it was a Nikon D60 at a
time and I shot my first music video for
a a guy he worked with at the at the at
the shoe store with and then I started
shooting videos and I started making
money and then I called Ivan I'm like yo
bro I just made 500 off a music video
you make 400 in two weeks working at a
shoe store you wanna um you wanna ride
with me and I didn't have a car at the
time so basically I pay I've been half
of the video just to drive me wow yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy that [ __ ] is wild
yeah and all my childhood best friends
like uh Joe on Andres Marquis all the
kids from my neighborhood they actually
work for my company you got me like
they're the head of production
um you know Joe wants you just put you
kind of helped put everybody on well
brought him with you yeah they well the
thing is they stuck with me you know
they were at my lowest yeah I mean there
was times where like I literally like I
used to walk I used to take three buses
to the tri world just to get to Miami to
get the Lex office like shout out to Lex
100 times like it's 11 at night and I
used to literally miss the trial leave
try to figure out how I'm gonna get home
and I don't want to call myself for
people who don't know Fort Lauderdale
but 40 minutes away about 35-40 minutes
away yeah so and like I didn't want to
call my parents because yeah I mean like
you know you're young and you're like I
don't want to bother my parents and if
they saw the places that I was going
they would have been like not what are
you doing you're not going out again
yeah man I used to be I used to be in
the hoods like yeah you know like
shooting Hood videos with people with
guns in my face you got me so it's just
like I show my parents that they're
gonna be like what are you doing one
time my mom um she was watching one of
my videos and uh there's an artist named
young fee and he was holding up a very
big piece of weed and she didn't know
and she's like is that is that chicken
you get I mean like like you know she
didn't she like she's a Spanish woman so
she doesn't understand now I'm like yeah
Mom and you know because they hated weed
and they're very traditional parents
because they come from Spanish countries
so it was just funny to see all that
kind of come together no that's crazy I
mean yeah I know it's dope to see just
kind of the start to yeah you know what
you're doing now and what you got coming
we gotta stop the interview tell you
about our partners at Odd Socks well
first of all let's check out the brand
new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know me yeah these are the Odd Socks
Basics all right so if you go to the
website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
uh what was the most nervous you've been
to shoot a video
oh man nervous
honestly damn I don't want to be that
guy saying I'm never nervous but
um
man honestly when I shot Tiffany haddish
with Russ I was like yo this is Tiffany
[ __ ] Superstar actress she's a you
know she just dropped the movie with
Nicolas Cage exactly great movie yeah
and I was like I was like all right so
like like and I'm directing dialogue and
I'm just like this is like a surreal
moment for me and I'm like Edgar it's
time yeah that's a real moment I said
it's time to show up you know and the
way we got Tiffany is funny because um I
got invited to this macro event
um and they throw this big pre-scars
parties with all these celebrities and I
was talking to Russ I'm like yo we need
to put a superstar in this uh like an
actress or something right someone's
gonna give it like notoriety and Russ
wanted to kind of be a little bit more
like funny and he's like everyone takes
me too serious I want to you know loosen
up a little bit and kind of like have
some dialogue so I can show people that
I'm actually just I'm this is who I am
right and um we're at this Prius parties
and I'm like yo Russ
Stephanie haddish and we walk up to her
and that's when we locked her in for the
video shout out to Jerome shout out to
Stephanie for connecting us but yeah we
saw her and we're like yo we want you in
the video and she's like she I don't
know if she knew who Russ was or maybe
she heard of him but she was like I'm
down and then she honestly she was down
to do it out of love too but then Russ
was like no I'm gonna pay you because I
respect your time and your energy and
your efforts so that was really
respectful for him um I do feel like man
you're kind of like a perfect example of
uh what it takes to really make it
because I feel like when I meet young up
and coming
artists or whatever you're trying to get
into it feels like there's a lot of
entitlement and a lot of um yeah
just a lot of entitlement and a lot of
times people just aren't willing to like
do the work do the work and also like
see the bigger picture yeah see the
longer play as opposed to the short
right away game shout out to my family
my mom and dad always told me like help
people not because you want something
from them but just help them if they're
in need and I just seen artists that
were super talented and you know and I
just I don't know I just believed you
know when you have that intuition and
that gut feeling like yo that person I
don't know they have something special
and that's what I saw in a guy's like
Ace Hood uh Jake Miller uh you know even
Khaled at the time and Russ and all
these artists little babies super early
you know I shot all his early videos as
well south side and all those ones in
the hood and it's like I was just like
yo these Arts are special and I had like
an a r here which ended up you know
leading to my record label yeah and um
and actually I think we're about to sign
another artist right now but um it was
just it was just funny like like your
ears and like just understanding that
like yo I think I know dope [ __ ] and
then I kind of took that into not only
like artists but into products so I've
invested a lot in you know you know a
heart Seltzer company an ice cream
company a non-GMO Flower Company sure so
it's like and I'm like I think these
Pirates gonna blow up and things started
going crazy and you're just like all
right cool I'm ahead of the curve and
I'm very grateful to have that kind of
like eye and talent you know 100 do you
think um
well first of all there's a lot of
[ __ ] heart Seltzer companies yeah 100
shout out to telago best game I should
have brought some yeah yeah how many
carbs are in it
um I'm not honestly I'm not even sure
you know but I know it's organic and I
know it tastes good and it's very light
and refreshing and the reason I got into
it because um shout out to Henny who hit
me up about it we shot the smino video
and he's like yo Edgar I think you'd be
a perfect partner and I was like all
right cool tell the CEO to pull up on me
today I'm at the Modern Hotel and he did
and I'm like that's the type of CEO I
want to work with I don't care what the
product is yeah I mean um you're
hustling you're here and I made some
comments for him that same day and we're
like let's go and like that's how I
could move you got me and I know it'll
get better throughout the project that's
kind of what happened with you with the
artists you something yeah right that's
kind of what I do I just kind of get
into things and I just go for it I don't
wait you know and I think I'll tell
everyone on camera like you can't wait
on anything you got to go get that [ __ ]
and like that's kind of why I keep
implementing that energy on my social
medias because I came to my C and be
like you know what today I just I'm
decided to go get it yeah it could
change his life obviously you got the
production company tons of side
businesses any other videos coming that
you can obviously just just
obviously the Nikki one's a big one yeah
Nick is good
um yeah um yeah I think I could say
um something potentially what M.I.A is
coming
um yeah um that's cool
yeah I know what I'm really looking
forward right now is taking American
artists and taking them outside of
America to shoot their videos you got me
it's because I feel like you know you go
to La you go to the same peer space or
gigster yeah and you see the same God
every period you go to peerspace.com and
I'm just like God I've seen like 30
videos that [ __ ] place that they shot
the uh Dark Knight at with the [ __ ]
lights on the ceiling yeah you know what
I'm talking about yeah we've all shot
videos oh my God damn how many videos
have been shot here and it's just about
and commercials like [ __ ] it's just
about pushing right now and like pushing
how far we can do it like I just scouted
a location and it was literally I'm
shooting at a college you got me and
it's totally different than some
anything I've ever seen so I'm like I
want to shoot there you got me and like
what is that key to like finding a good
location because that is something that
like you said if you go I I kind of feel
like if you go about like
the super proper way if you're kind of
like a young independent shooter and you
you probably have a little bit more
leeway and just like saying hey I think
we can get this shot on like three
minutes without permits like yeah and
that's the thing it's about taking your
time right and like you know really like
I used to shoot videos like I shot this
video for this band one time and we
traveled to Red Rocks um then we
traveled to Vegas then we travel to
um Salt Lake City and in between that
there was like snow somewhere like a
patch of snow and a shot there too and I
shot this worldly ass video that you
would think that it took like it was
like a National Geographic video but it
was really just like a matter of two
days and just traveling and just
stopping and finding these open roads
where nobody's at and putting in that
effort
um same thing with gashi like you know I
shot a video of ragashi where you know
um you know we drove all the way to
Vegas just to shoot it you know just to
get those those scenes yeah I love gashi
I shot his first video disrespectful
that I'm getting online yeah that record
was crazy yeah I heard it he was
actually writing a song for Jake Miller
and then um the studio he was writing
songs for a lot of people too yeah he
wrote this uh he was at a studio session
and then um yeah Jake and him um they
were having a hard time getting a song
together so uh Jake left early and then
gashi stayed and he just took the studio
time and I was like there's something
special about this guy and he was
talking so abrasive you know how gosh
she took it she's just very like in your
face and I was like I was like yo this
guy I think I'm yo Jake I'm gonna stay
and I stayed and he was like yo let me
play you my album
and then he played the song like that
ended up shooting five years later with
sting on it yeah hey mama hey mama yeah
and then um you shot the sting video
yeah and then um but he played me that
song five years prior to that moment you
got me and he had that that's so crazy
and then I was like yo that song right
there is gonna be a hit and then he and
also he played disrespectful and I'm
like yo we gotta shoot that next week so
I didn't have a car at the time still
undocumented in L.A and I was living
with Jake and shout out to Jake because
if it wasn't for him I couldn't sign a
lease or nothing and like I really
appreciate it because I only had to pay
a thousand dollars and shoot one music
video for him a month and I was like
[ __ ] great I was like I can do that
you know and I could afford that
and yeah man it just came to a situation
where I saw gashi and I was like yo I
believe in you and at that time I'm
doing
you know 50 17 000 music videos yeah his
1985 uh yeah album is incredible yeah
and um and his new stuff is crazy too
like yeah he's incredible yeah he's one
of those artists that like
it's just a matter like I mean I somehow
but I'm not gonna get into where he was
at perfect I feel like
he's a superstar that's what I mean and
the thing is one thing about gosh I'm
gonna say and if anyone has a
misconstrued on him and is like when you
call him he picks up the phone yeah you
know he facetimes you he asks you how
you are not what you do so I really just
appreciate that honestly like he's a
really good guy like um sometimes maybe
misunderstood but right it's that same
misunderstood in confidence that got him
to where he is today so 100 I always
think back to that video him like in the
meeting playing his records and just
[ __ ] that's how he is everywhere yeah
no and that's that's why that's that's
the type of confidence people need to
get like I had to go and be like in 2010
be like I'm gonna be the biggest music
video director in the world watch you
know next year I'm gonna be directing a
video for Nicki Minaj and I always post
those before and afters just so people
can see like where it stems from like
and I like I think a lot of people see
that with Draymond Green they're like
why is he so confident like yo like to
get to the NBA to win four championships
like bro it's different you got me and
it's just like especially not being the
star and stuff like that and being told
you're not the star every every year
it's like and still having that much
impact on the team like the real ones
know you know there it is man well
listen uh go follow this guy he's
posting hella inspirational content
outside of just doing amazing work uh
what's your IG let everybody know yeah
my ig's Edgar Estevez
e-d-g-a-r-e-s-t-e-v-e-s
um follow the company blank score
production spell the way it's on the Hat
um Kev just want to give you your
flowers too I appreciate all everything
you're doing I watch every interview a
lot of these interviews honestly like
and directors like you guys before
writing a concept for a video watch The
Wiz interview you hear me you know what
I'm saying like understand that he was
in the studio having streams with him
like listening the album eight times
yeah I mean a lot of people won't do
their research on artists and if you
want to direct videos in hip-hop care
about hip-hop artists you got me don't
come from another genre and think you're
just gonna come over here use them as
clout and then spit them back out yeah I
mean that's not what I do that's why I
still work with emerging artists and
that's why I built a company so my
directors can build with them and grow
with them because it's their time now
yeah and I just I just want to say that
and you know that's the message I you
know I wanted to come kind of come here
and say so I appreciate you brother
thank you man go run it up man go watch
all his [ __ ] and uh shout out your
artist one more time uh iv4 and shout
out to everyone who just helped me along
my journey good or bad I appreciate you
it's a great journey man yeah there it
is Edgar boom